look who just got here
come give me a big hug
sorry this is how
this is why I don't get on Tick Tock
much stormy Webster crashes mom Kylie
Jenner's makeup tutorial before a
precious Cameo from her baby brother air
I love you
deep down like I would love my true fans
to know like all my personal stuff Kylie
shares the moment to Tick-Tock
addressing her on-again off-again
relationship with the platform okay I
don't have a lot of time but I wanted to
come on here because I haven't in a
while in between beauty secrets Kylie
points out why she's not posting as much
these days I'm really into doing my
makeup super fast I have two kids now
look who just got here come give me a
big hugs
I love you mommy forever
I love you
[Music]
there's baby noises in the background
but hey at least storm became bearing
gifts
what are you doing
of course stormy is a well-known scene
stealer on Mom's social media
oh okay
here like her candy Obsession during a
tour of Kylie Cosmetics two years ago
get out of here
I feel like I'm getting into so many
cool Beauty things now Beauty Moguls all
work no play in the Kardashians season 3
teaser we have huge influence what are
we doing with our power
so
let's talk about it this comes as we're
hearing Kylie and rapper Travis Scott
pressed pause on their relationship
a source tells E.T Kylie is solely
focused on her kids and work right now
adding that she's trying to stay
positive and wants things to be balanced
and remain drama-free
[Music]
The Insider notes that the two love and
respect each other and will continue to
co-parent and while Kylie's love life
may be in flux
she's staying focused on work and
wellness sharing this video of her
morning Fitness routine
[Music]
I'm obsessed with it meanwhile Kylie's
teasing more Tick Tock content but we'll
understand if she needs another breather
sorry this is how
that's why I don't get on Tick Tock much
I'll see you soon talk
even if you can be a little crazy
[Music]